ANKUR KOTWAL: Good afternoon
everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
My name is Ankur Kotwal, and
I'm an Android Developer
Advocate from Sydney,
Australia.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi.
I'm Chris Broadfoot.
I work on the Google Maps API
team, also in Sydney.
And today we're going to talk
to you about the Google Maps
Android API v2, which to some
of you may be quite new.
It was really since last year's
Google I/O. And it was
released late last year, 2012.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So what we really
want to show you today
is cool ways that you can use
the API to really not just
build basic maps--
or include basic maps, but
really rich, detailed maps.
So we're going to show you some
of the capabilities of
the library itself, but then
also show you how you can mix
in Android sensors and Google
Maps web services.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes.
So the format of this talk is
three demos, and then we'll
take a deep dive into each demo
and show you how they
were built and the interesting
aspects of each demo.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So why don't we
start with the first demo.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
So you'll see on this app,
we have two maps on here.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Wait,
Ankur, two maps?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh, yes.
Sorry I should explain that.
We said maps for
Android API v2.
The 2 actually means you
can have two maps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Dude,
we went through this.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Oh,
sorry, sorry.
No, no, no.
What it means is that you can
have as many maps as you want.
This is something developers
have been asking for a while,
because with the old API, you
could only have one map at a
time, right.
Well, now you can have
as many as you want.
Obviously, you want to tailor
you user experience
accordingly.
So having 15 on there, probably
not such a good thing.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, so before
we get into it, do you want to
explain what we're getting
at here with the demo.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, sure.
So have you ever wondered how
long it takes you to get from
the airport when you arrived to
take a flight to the point
where you get to your
destination?
Well, it turns out that if you
live in Sydney, anywhere you
go is a long, long time--
mainly because of the flight.
But what we did is we were
curious about this
information, and we built an
app, which kind of shows us
our journey through
the airport.
And we wanted to tell this
story using maps.
So going back to it, you
see two maps here.
On the left hand side is me.
On the right hand
side is Chris.
We've actually both arrived at
Sydney airport, but we got
dropped off by cabs
at opposite ends.
So I was at the northern
end, and Chris was at
the southern end.
So let's start the story.
The best way to start a story,
actually, is to move the
distractions out of the way.
So Chris we're going
to get rid of you.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Excuse me.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We're going to
focus on me for a minute.
This is me walking through
Sydney airport, and I've just
walked inside Sydney airport,
and the first thing I've done
is stopped to see the screens
to see where I can
go and check in.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Can you explain
this green trail
that's behind you?
Is that a realistic
representation of what
actually happened?
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, I can promise
you I wasn't leaving a
green trail behind me as I
walked through the airport.
That's a polyline.
And what I'm doing is using the
polyline to visualize my
path through Sydney airport.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
Good to know.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Do you have
any more questions?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
I will, I will.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right, so this
is me walking to counter
D, and oop--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: There's
me, there's me.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Just as I arrived
at counter D, Chris
and I ran into one another,
where we pretty much checked
in at the same time.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And
what happened next?
ANKUR KOTWAL: We then started
to make our way through
security and immigration.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Well,
we've merged.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We have.
We're now one.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this is a
new feature that we released
in the latest version of Google
Play services, and
that's set icon.
Now that might not sound
like very much.
But it means that you don't have
to swap out your marker
objects just to change
the icon.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
set icon, whoo.
If you've ever been through
Sydney airport on a weekend,
through immigration and
security, you probably know
how horrendously
slow it can be.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Almost as
bad as LA, or so I hear.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Actually,
not as bad as LA.
Nothing's as bad as LA.
Anyways, we went through
security and we're going to
make our way through.
And you'll notice on the bottom
right there's a little
icon that shows us walking.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So is this new
activity recognition API?
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's right.
So as you notice here, every
time we move on the map, we're
showing a little icon
to represent
that we were walking.
That information was actually
gathered through the Activity
Recognition API that was also
launched in Google Play
services 3.1.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So speaking
of walking along the map, I
notice that we're animating
these markers on the map, and
that's not exactly a
feature of the API.
There's no walking of markers.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yes,
that's right.
We are actually moving the
marker without creating a new
marker every time.
We're going to show you
some code on how we
animate these markers.
But for now what we'll do
is continue the story.
Sydney airport, once you get
through security, they force
you to go through Duty Free.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's
very confusing.
I feel like I'm in an Ikea or
something, but there's just
perfume everywhere.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And frankly, even
though we were doing some
shopping, there's only so much
perfume you can buy.
So we finally got through
the stores and got out.
And at this point, we realized
that bah, we actually have
more time for our flights
than we first expected.
So we thought, well, what should
we do to kill the time?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Well, there's
really only one option.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, I mean
it's the Australian way.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
just drink beer.
All the time.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We went
to the lounge.
And there's that icon
on the bottom
right-hand corner again.
But this is us traveling
to the lounge.
We sat down at the lounge, had
a good chat, and although we
were only going to stay for one
drink, we stayed for a few
more, and a few more
after that.
And then we heard
an announcement.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It
was our names.
I heard our names many times.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, it was our
names and they were telling us
that they were going to throw
our luggage off of the flight,
if we didn't get to
the gate quickly.
So we panicked.
And we started running
to the gate.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: You panicked.
I just followed.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You can see us now
running and moving along
with the map a lot faster.
You can see the animations
have sped up here.
And we've also added this
yellow glow to kind of
accentuate the sort of stress
that we were feeling.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And so that's
just a view on top of the map.
ANKUR KOTWAL: It's just
an image view.
The other thing that
that yellow glow--
the purpose that it serves is
that it sort of adds a bit of
a haze over the map, and
frankly, that's what we were
seeing after our time
at the lounge.
Anyways, the good news is,
we got on our flight.
We took off, and we were able
to make it here on time to
give you this presentation.
And we got to San Francisco.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I think
next year, we
should stop at Hawaii.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I've never seen
a lounge in Hawaii.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We're just
going straight past there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Absolutely.
So here we are.
San Francisco airport.
Landed safe and sound.
And I just want to point out
here, it's a beautiful map.
It's an indoor map of San
Francisco airport, and even in
Sydney airport, there was an
indoor map that was showing us
as we were traversing through
the various sections.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this
is a new feature in
the Google Maps API.
And it's on by default.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right, well,
why don't we talk about how we
put this together.
And really we can't talk about
it without talking about
Google Play services.
For many of you that have been
in presence at I/O, you
probably have heard a bit about
Google Play services,
but for those of you watching
on YouTube, Google Play
services is a way the APIs are
delivered to users devices.
So it's an APK that gets
installed alongside with the
Google Play store and
automatically updated.
So the fantastic news for
everyone in this room is all
of the demos we're showing you
today, they're using APIs that
are already available
for all your users.
Android 2.2 and up,
o or Froyo and up.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, I mean
the other great thing is as
the Google Maps API team keeps
making improvements like bug
fixes, enhancements, and new
features, your users
automatically get that
functionality, and your app
automatically gets better.
So you don't have to
redeploy your app.
Your users don't have
to upgrade.
Everything just gets better.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And the good thing
is you don't actually
have to-- well, you mentioned
you don't have to redeploy
your app, but in terms of new
features that get rolled out,
you can incorporate them
straight away.
As soon as we talk about it
publicly, they're available.
All right, MapFragment.
I think there's probably many of
you in this room that have
had angry blog posts about us
releasing MapFragments.
We could only have one
map at a time.
So I'm hoping we don't have the
same angry mob this time
that we had in previous I/Os.
The good news is once you've
incorporated the Maps API
library in your app--
and that's just by including the
static lib for Google Play
services, the thin wrapper--
you just need an API key, and
then you can use MapFragments
straight away.
So here is a layout.
And all we've done is dropped
two MapFragments in, and we're
good to go.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: There's also a
support MapFragment, if you
need to support ICS
and below--
oh, sorry, no, below ICS.
Of course ICS you can use
MapFragment directly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So by default
MapFragments give you the full
capability of maps.
So you get outdoor mapping,
indoor mapping.
You get all the gestures.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So by default the map
is fully featured.
You don't need to
enable gestures
or any other features.
You get the default controls.
You can easily enable the
my-location layer, which we'll
show you a little
bit later on.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Obviously, as
developers, you can turn those
features off, if you want to
have a very fine-grain control
for your users.
Or if you want to provide
your own zoom buttons or
my-location buttons.
So we give you capabilities
to do that.
Let's talk about markers
and animating makers.
So let's look at some code.
Chris was asking how we moved
those markers around.
Basically, what we're doing is
periodically setting the
position on our markers.
So we're using a Handler
to do that.
And what we do is we grab the
start time when we want to
kick off a marker animation.
And then when our Handler
executes, we work out how much
time has elapsed and adjust
the position of the marker
accordingly.
I want to make a special call
out to this thing that we're
using called an interpolater.
We're using a linear
interpolator, so in effect
we're moving the marker linearly
across that time.
But you could use a different
interpolator, something like
an accelerate-decelerate
interpolator, which allows the
marker to start very slowly
and speed up and then slow
down once again.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, sorry.
So this is particularly useful
for camera transitions, but
also for animating markers.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
So if you wanted to use a
different interpolator--
you might have a car moving
along a map that speeds up and
has to break really hard, and
you could do that with an
interpolator.
All right, so once we've
calculated the values we want
to set, we just go
ahead and set the
position off that marker.
And just before we
reinitialize--
or we tell the Handler that you
need to run again in 16
milliseconds.
Now, you may be thinking that
16 milliseconds seems like a
magic number.
Well, it's actually not.
It's a number that you'll see
time and time again, because
Android devices typically
render at 60 frames per
second, which means you
get 16 milliseconds
to render each frame.
So the reason that number 16
milliseconds is here is
because we're asking the Handler
to run again for the
next frame.
Now, Chris you mentioned the
line that was following me--
that was a polyline--
but we have other types
of shape that we
can draw, as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So for those
of you not familiar with
polylines, they're essentially
a list of latitude and
longitude points.
And polygons are very similar.
They're a list of latitude and
longitude points once again,
but enclosed.
So polygons can actually
have a fill,
because they're enclosed.
And they can also have holes.
I haven't seen this
slide before.
Ankur, that's a very strange
geographic feature.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's
just a Bugdroid.
You should know this.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So the holes you can see here
represented with the eyes and
obviously can have different
styling.
So you can see here, the
Bugdroid's body has a black
stroke, and his antennae--
I think that's what they're
called, or ears--
don't have a stroke.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So for the eyes,
they're actually truly holes.
We haven't put another
polygon on top
that's a different color.
It's actually a cut out of
a hole, and you can do
that with the API.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Exactly.
So we also have circles, which
are a special case of polygon,
where each point is an equal
distance from the center.
So you just specify center and
a radius, but remember this
radius is specified in meters.
So this is a feature on the
surface of the earth, it's not
specified in screen space.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
Now, I want to make another
mention of indoor maps,
because really they allowed us
to have such a rich story to
tell in an indoor location
like Sydney airport.
Without indoor maps, Sydney
airport and San Francisco
airport would have just been
gray or brown boxes.
So indoor maps are great, and as
we mentioned, you get them
by default.
As developers, of course, you
have an API that allows you to
turn off indoor maps, if for
whatever reason you don't want
to show indoor map locations
on your map.
And the other thing to keep in
mind is that if you have
multiple MapFragments, we're
only showing indoor maps today
on one of the fragments
at a time.
It is based on the first map
that gets drawn, but that's
OK, because we have a
nice API that allows
you to control that.
So all you do is tell all of
your MapFragments to turn off
indoor, and turn it on for the
one fragment that you do you
really want to show it on.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And the other
thing you may have noticed in
Sydney airport there were two
levels, so the user can change
between the levels.
That's there by default
as well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
Activity recognition.
This is one of my favorite new
features of Google Play
Services 3.1, because it allows
developers to register
for call backs when the activity
that the user is
taking changes.
So you can find out whether the
user is still, whether the
device is tilting, or you can
find out directly whether
they're on foot, they're on a
bike, or they're driving.
Now this is really, really
useful information, because it
can affect the way you
might want to present
your app to the user.
If you're showing a map and you
can tell that they're in a
car that's moving faster,
so they're driving--
well, hopefully not driving, but
a passenger in the car--
you can zoom out your
map so that it's not
animating too quickly.
And you can do that passively.
These are the types of
delightful experiences that
your users will maybe
consciously notice, but
definitely subconsciously
it'll be a better
experience for them.
So in Google Now, at the end of
the month, you actually--
many of you have probably seen
this card that tells you this
is the activity that you
undertook over the month.
We are actually using
the same APIs--
the activity recognition APIs--
that you all have
access to now as well.
So the other thing I want to
mention is that there's a
great talk on activity
recognition called,
Behind the Blue Dot.
And for those of you in this
room, it's already happened
this morning, but you can go
and watch it on YouTube.
So for everyone, if you haven't
seen it, it's a really
great talk on how to use
the API as well as
how they built it.
And finally, we also have a code
lab tomorrow that shows
you how to implement activity
recognition in your apps, and
we can't wait to see what
you can do with it.
All right, let's do
one more demo.
This one is called a tour of San
Francisco, and the reason
I want to show it off is because
this showcases my
favorite feature of
the Maps API.
And that's the camera.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this demo's
demonstrating that you
have full programmatic
access to the camera.
You can see that there's
beautiful 3D buildings, and
we're just transitioning between
these different camera
viewpoints very smoothly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So all we do here
is we animate the camera,
and we randomly assign
a tilt and a bearing.
Where you'll notice that when
we move from location to
location, we get this
beautiful zoom out
and zoom back in.
The 3D buildings just
look marvelous.
The maps themselves are
vector maps, so
they always stay sharp.
And it just generally provides
such a nice cinematic
experience.
It's like doing those kind of
flyover through San Francisco.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So it's worth
noting that this demo is just
showing the programmatic access
to the camera, but your
users have full access to these
changes in cameras as
well through the use
of gestures.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right,
switch back to slides.
In general, camera on
Maps API, awesome.
Make full use of it.
As you include it in your maps,
don't think of your map
as just something flat.
Think of how you can make
it more tactile.
Let me show you some
code on how we are
animating the camera.
We first create a CameraPosition
object.
And this is basically saying,
where do I want
the camera to be.
We're able to specify a
location, tilt, bearing, and
zoom level as well.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Now, be aware
that you can specify the zoom
level as a float.
So you can actually have
a fractional zoom.
So you're not limited to
discreet zoom levels.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah,
it's continuous.
Now, the other thing we can do
is actually chain animation.
So in our demo just then, what
we were doing was once we got
to a destination, we were moving
it to the next one.
So you can do it with a listener
like we have here.
When we pass it in, it lets us
know when the animation is
complete, so it can trigger
the next one.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So there's also
a onCancel call back, and
this will be triggered, for
example, if the user has
panned away while the
animation's in progress.
So if you were expecting to do
something when the animation
is finished, maybe you could
do something else, if it's
been canceled.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
Let's have a look at
one more demo.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So, Ankur, have
you ever traveled to a
city and had absolutely
no idea what to do?
Maybe you've woken up
in the hotel and
you've got a day off.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's actually
the type of
traveler that I am, Chris.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Disorganized.
ANKUR KOTWAL: No, no, no.
Spontaneous.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So Ankur and I thought it would
be cool to build a demo
to address this use case.
So once again this
is just a demo.
It's not app quality.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And so here
we are in Moscone.
And, oh, bummer, there we go.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So we had an
interesting location there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So the first thing
we did was actually ask
for location.
And the map started off
with our location.
It took a moment to get that,
but now that we have it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
so we're using
the my-location layout.
Now this is just one flag that
you set, and you get the
my-location button, which you
can see in the top right, and
when the user presses that,
the map is panned over to
their current location, and a
blue dot is displayed on the
map directly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Now, I noticed,
Chris, that we have some red
markers on here.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes, so these
points are coming through the
Places API, which is
a web service.
So you just fire off a HTTP
request, and you get back all
this interesting
location data.
So if I just click on one of
these, and see that we're
getting some interesting
places around here.
A lot of hotels.
All hotels.
OK, good.
And in the info window, which is
displayed about the market
we're just showing
the placement.
Now info window is fully
customizable.
You can have your own custom
views through an info window
adapter, but here we're just
showing the place name.
Very simple.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I also noticed
that there's this blue circle
that's growing out
from the center.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
So we're just using a circle,
which we talked about a little
bit earlier, and we're
animating the
radius of that circle.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And this is a
neat visualization trick,
because it's actually showing
us how far out from our
location we're searching.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes, so this
showing to the user that the
Places search is contained
within that radius.
Just a nice visual indicator.
And in fact, I've added
a long press listener.
So if I long press over here,
the Places search then moves
over to that new location, and
the user can see that they've
got some feedback that this is
the new center of the search.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So why don't we
pick a place that we might
want to add to our itinerary?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, so I'm a
big fan of the Marina, so
let's go over to Fisherman's
Wharf.
You can see here that we've
painted a line from our
location, which was provided
through the location API to
the location that I've
just pressed.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Now this is
a polyline, but there's
something interesting about
it, because it's not a
straight line from
where we started.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Exactly.
It's actually the recommend
path for walking.
And this data came from the
Directions API, which again is
a web service.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Now, I'm also
noticing that we have some
extra information here on
the left-hand side.
Not just the name, but we have
the distance and the time that
it would take us to do this.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Precisely.
So this information also came
through the Directions API.
And you'll notice that
the sidebar says
2.1 miles, 43 minutes.
These values are localized from
the API, so you don't
have to worry about localizing
inside your app,
which is very handy.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
Now there's this button
here, Magic Camera.
You want to show us what
that is, Chris?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Oh, Magic
Camera's my favorite.
OK.
So you'll notice that the map is
moving around a little bit
as I'm holding the device.
ANKUR KOTWAL: I thought that's
just because you're nervous.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I am a little
nervous, yes, that's true.
OK, so as I hold the device up,
you'll see the map it's
tilting and zooming
at the same time.
Now, once again, I'll just put
the tablet down and you can
see that it's zoomed out, and
it's flat once again.
So let's go back up.
And you can say that the 3D
buildings start to to appear
as I've brought the device up.
Now you can imagine that your
user's picked up their device,
and they're looking out to the
world in front of them.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So if you're
thinking about it from the use
case that we started with, an
itinerary app, this is a nice
third person view.
We can see what's
in front of us.
If we were to visit
this location,
what's in this direction?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Exactly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So speaking
of direction,
what's in that direction?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So let's move the tablet over
there a little bit.
So once again we're using the
senses in the device to detect
the position, the orientation
of the device in the real
world and using these values
to alter the Maps camera.
So it's a little awkward if it
was turning here, that's
turning my back to you.
But you can see the
city behind us.
And as I keep panning around.
Let's put the tablet down.
So this is almost as though
the user's going
into planning mode.
You can imagine someone laying
down a paper map and spreading
it out all in front of them.
Once again, I'm going
to long press.
Let's head over to Alcatraz.
So we're going to get walking
directions over there, Ankur.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, hold on.
That was interesting, because
we asked for walking
directions, but out from our
blue marker, we went right and
then up towards it.
What's up with that?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So this
is actually us
getting onto a ferry.
Because there's no way of
directly walking over there,
the Directions API has added a
step for the ferry itself.
This is also reflected
in the time.
You can see that it takes 29
minutes over 2.7 miles to get
over there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So you're telling
me the Directions API
not just does walking and
driving, but we get public
transport information,
as well?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Exactly.
So let's hop into magic camera
on Alcatraz, because I think
that's pretty cool.
And you can see Alcatraz there
and the path that you used to
walk up to the top.
ANKUR KOTWAL: It even has the
path from where we got to the
ferry terminal up to the actual
entrance of the island.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Awesome.
Let's see how we put
this together.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So let's talk about Magic
Camera, because that's one of
my favorite things
about this demo.
So first of all, let's talk
about this sensor data.
We're using the rotation
vector sensor.
Now, Ankur, you did a talk at
last year's Google I/O about
Android sensors.
Can you tell us a bit more
about this sensor?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah, so the
rotation vector sensor is an
interesting one, because it
doesn't map directly to a
hardware sensor.
It actually aggregates
multiple sensors.
It uses the accelerometer,
the gyroscope, and the
magnetometer.
So the nice thing about it is
that you get some very nice
data, because its
algorithmically putting that
together and presenting
it you in a nice way.
But even better than that, you
don't actually have to check
whether that particular sensor
exists, because if the
gyroscope isn't on that
particular Android device,
this sensor will-- because it's
a fuse sensor-- it'll
still give you back data.
It'll do the best that it can
do with the sensors that it
has access to.
So the rotation vector was
introduced in Android 2.3, or
Gingerbread.
But it's really cool
from that sense.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: I've also
noticed that the data that
comes back from the sensor is
quite clean, so you only have
to do very small amounts
of data cleaning on it.
So reading from it
is very simple.
We just simply register
a listener
with our update interval.
So here again, we're using 16
milliseconds to get an update
for every frame.
And the listener's
just very simple.
To avoid allocations for every
frame, we just preallocate an
array and keep them as fields.
And then for each update, we
just populate those fields
with the relevant data.
So we read the rotation matrix
from the sensor's event
values, and then convert that
rotation matrix into three
values that are more
applicable for most
applications, and that's
azimuth, tilt and roll.
We're ignoring roll for this
demo and just using azimuth,
which you can essentially
consider to be the direction
that north is in, and
tilt, which is just
the device's tilt.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
So if you're hearing us talk
about the rotation vector and
you're hearing words like
matrices, and they're scaring
you, the nice thing is we have
some utility functions that
handle it for you, and that's
all the code that you need to
transform it into usable
information on maps.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Exactly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Let's
see how we use it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK.
So it's actually a very simple
mapping between those azimuth
and tilt and all of the
camera's properties.
So we need to clamp the
tilt between zero
and 67 and 1/2 degrees.
Those are the acceptable values
for the Maps API.
We can just pass the Azimuth
straight through to the
bearing property.
We don't need to do any mod by
360 or anything like that.
The API handles that for you.
And the more interesting thing
is the mapping between tilt of
the device and the map's zoom.
So we just essentially need to
zoom in as the map is brought
out toward you, and zoom out
when the map is put down.
So we start at a minimum of 13,
which is zoomed out, and
they go up to 18,
which is where
buildings start to appear.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Now, I notice
also in this code, Chris,
you're doing moveCamera, whereas
then in the demo that
I did I was doing
animateCamera.
So can you just tell us
a little bit about the
differences between those two?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes, so
essentially I used moveCamera,
which just snaps the
camera into place.
AnimateCamera will animate
transitions smoothly into the
new camera position.
Whereas moveCamera just
goes straight there.
And so that was useful in this
demo, because we're updating
the camera every frame, so
there's no point animating
between them.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Now one of the
recurring themes at I/O 2013
has been about how you
can delight users.
And sometimes delighting users
means putting in functionality
that they may not actually
notice, but is actually
significantly improving
the experience.
So Chris had something in his
demo that I think really
delights the user but isn't
necessarily obvious.
And we want to show that now.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And, yeah,
excuse me if this explain
explanation's a little bit
convoluted, but I'm going to
talk about this offset
camera target.
Now you may have noticed, if
you just look on the left,
this is what happens if we
continually animate the
bearing around a
certain point.
So we're pivoting the map
around the blue point.
OK.
So if you thought about the
itinerary demo, if you brought
the tablet up, and you're
looking around, it's not a
very good experience, because
you're seeing all of these
markers that are essentially
behind you,
behind the pivot point.
So in the demo, we actually
offset the pivot point by a
certain number of meters.
Now this is just a bit of magic
so that as you put the
map down, the pivot point is in
the center of the map and
not at the bottom of the map,
but you can experiment with
this a little bit.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So as you're
holding it up from a third
person point of view, the
right-hand side is actually a
much nicer experience, because
you're seeing what's in front
of you, and it's really
truly providing you a
third person view.
But when it's flat,
you do want to
see as much as possible.
So this is just a subtle tweak,
but one that really
makes a difference
to the experience
that the users have.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So if you look
at the right-hand side
map, the blue marker is still
the center of the map, but
you'll notice that
it's actually
moving across the world.
It's actually moving across
on that blue circle.
The red point is the pivot point
and that's essentially
what we're animating
our bearing around.
So this is achieved through a
function called computeOffset,
which is just a way of getting
another point on the surface
of the earth a certain number
of meters and with a certain
bearing away from
another point.
So here the mLatLng variable is
the pivot point, and we're
just offsetting that by a
certain number of meters.
It's magic.
And we're just passing through
that azimuth once again, which
we used for the bearing.
And that's why that point
essentially doesn't move as
the camera's moving,
because those two
properties are bound together.
So this spherical util
is available at
github.com/googlemaps.
And it's in the Android Maps
utils library, and there's a
whole bunch of really great
functions in there.
If you're familiar with our
JavaScript API, it's all of
those functions.
Things like computing the length
of the path or the area
of a polygon.
OK.
Let's move on.
So let's talk about
the Places API.
We mentioned that it's
a web service.
This means that you have to send
an HTTP web request to
get back the data.
So here send it to
maps.googeapis.com.
You do need an API
key once again.
And you just pass through
the center of the
search and the radius.
We're also specifying
a types filter.
You can filter over 100 types.
For example, restaurants,
lodging.
We saw a lot of hotels, so maybe
you want to filter out
the lodging.
And also art galleries,
and things like that.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So let's
look at their JSON
response that we get back.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yes, so you
get back a whole bunch of
interesting information.
In this demo, we use the lat,
long parts of the geometry.
And we just pass those straight
through to the marker
to display that information
on the map.
We also use the title.
And, we didn't use the rating
or the reference.
The reference is great if you
need to go and fetch more data
about that place or show
some business photos.
ANKUR KOTWAL: We've already
talked about animating one or
two markers.
But when you have lots of
markers, like we did in that
demo when we moved from location
to location, we
cleared one set of markers.
We added new markers.
You have to do a little bit
of marker management.
So this is a topic we get asked
about from time to time,
so we thought it'd be good
to shed some light on it.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so
because we only had two
classes of markers, the best way
to store that was in two
different hash maps.
We are using for the place
results, just a
regular hash map.
And it's a mapping between the
marker and the relevant place
result data.
That object could be anything
that you like.
We're using a linked hash map
for the destinations.
And this is just because a
linked hash map provides a
consistent ordering as you
iterate over them, so that's
great if you need, for
example, a list.
So here we can see that the
blue markers are the
destinations, and the red
markers are the place results.
So this is useful, as Ankur
said, when you need to perform
a clearing of a particular
sort of maker.
So here we're just iterating
over the place result markers
and just clearing them before
we clear that map, before we
re-add the results from
the new array.
You can also do great things
like in the info window, click
listener, or all on market,
click listener, go and
look up that data.
So here, we're actually just
ignoring the clicks for the
destination markers.
But you could imagine switching
behavior based on
whether a look up to that map
was successful or not.
So using markers as keys for
maps is really good.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Let's look at how
we did the visualization
of the search radius.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So it's just
a very simple animation,
animating the radius and some
of the visual properties, so
in this case just the stroke
of the circle.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And we're
using what's called a
value animator here.
So this is a really neat set
of utility classes that we
added to Ice Cream Sandwich,
called a
property animation framework.
And what it allows you to do is
in really trivial amounts
of code, you can animate values
on your class from a
start to an end point and
provide a duration.
You can also provide
an interpolator.
In shorthand, it's really nice
to be able to use it.
So if you're targeting Ice Cream
Sandwich or later, the
property animation framework
is a great thing to use.
If you are targeting older
versions, you can use a
Handler to achieve
a similar effect.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And I believe
you could use an Object
Animator, if you're only
animating one property.
So if it's just radius,
you do that much more
easily than this even.
OK.
So let's talk about the
Directions API.
This was the other web service
that we use in this example.
So this is one of a suite of
Google Maps web services.
You're just passing the origin
and destination.
Here we're using the latitude
and longitude values for
accuracy, but you could also
pass through an address, and
the Directions API will go and
geocode that to these same
latitude and longitude.
You get back very detailed
information, actually
turn-by-turn directions
and all of the
points for those steps.
In this demo, we didn't
use any of that stuff.
We used the distance,
the duration,
and an overview polyline.
As we said, the distance and
duration are localized, but of
course, because it's an API, you
get back structured data,
so you get back meters
and seconds as well.
And this is great for example,
if we wanted to display the
total time, total walking
time, or total distance.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And you
mentioned that
the values are localized.
So obviously, in the States,
we get it as miles.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Or
feet as well.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Most of the rest
of the world uses the metric
system, so it'll be nicely
converted to
kilometers for you.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah, so this
overview polyline may look
like a whole bunch
of gibberish.
I personally can decode
it on the fly.
I don't know about you guys.
But I have released some code
in the same utility library
that will help you decode this
into a list of latitude and
longitude points.
And you pass that straight
through to a polyline.
And you can see here this is the
line that's represented by
this interesting string.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So we're not using
any of the levels there,
we're just using the
points, right?
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
So it's a much more compact
format than sending down all
of those numbers.
ANKUR KOTWAL: All right.
Well, to summarize, today we've
talked about the maps
API and just how much control
you have over it.
Things like the camera.
Things like indoor maps.
We've also talked about how
we can add other bits of
information to provide a better
experience for our users.
Sensors.
Or even the Google Maps
web services.
So we hope that this is the type
of talk that you can take
back and build some apps that
really delight us, because
we'd love to hear about them.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
And so the other one
thing that I'd like
to leave you with.
If you guys out there have a map
that's using the v1 Maps
API, or MapView, I strongly
encourage you to upgrade to
the new API.
It's very easy to get going and
will delight your users.
It's a massive improvement
in UI and API over
the existing MapView.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And continuously
updated.
CHRIS BROADFOOT:
Yeah, exactly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Thanks to
Google Play Services.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So for those of
you here in person, we are
running a code lab tomorrow
afternoon.
And for those of you that can't
attend in person, please
do go and check out the online
resources on both the Android
developer resources
and the Google
Maps developer resources.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Thank you very
much for your time today.
[APPLAUSE]